on pourrait se demander à ce moment là
est ce que nous sommes plus libres dans
le confinement ou moins libre ce serait
une question que se serait posé jean
paul sartre il s'imposait pour leurs
relations
là encore ça va dépendre des individus
mais bon on n'est pas occupé donc je ne
dirais pas comme j'en prends savent
qu'on n'a jamais été aussi que sous
l'occupation mais on a une certaine
maîtrise son temps on peut se livrer à
des ce que paul valéry après j'aime
beaucoup cette expression des loisirs
long chronométrique
on a plus de rendez vous donc on peut
donner aux choses le temps qu'elle
mérite
et puis choisir de les commencer ou les
interrompre un peu comme on veut donc ça
nous donne une forme de liberté en
essais mais en même temps il ya cette
forme d'oppression qui vient du
sentiment de ne pas pouvoir s'évader ne
pas pouvoir fuir et on n'a pas besoin de
fuir pour se sentir libre on a besoin de
sentir qu'on pourrait fuir son boulet et
là on en est privée est sacrée et
semaines la situation paradoxale et
derby de façon générale moi je dirais
que le confinement c'est un lob sur tous
les plans c'est un mélange d'urgence
dans certains endroits notamment les
hôpitaux et de très grande tranquillité
dans les rues c'est un mélange de divers
d'hyper connectivité on est tous de
plusieurs heures devant nos écrans et en
même temps de jachère sociale et donc il
ya ce mélange très bizarre de
contradictoire qui font que c'est une
expérience inédite et moi je crois que
c'est le seul événement historique réel
que j'aurai vécu dans ma vie
[Musique]